we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine to david p here's
a voicemail that came in that I'll play
for you I David I want to thank you very
much for tackling the cannabis situation
here in America the the topic that you
needed to be addressed in you guessed it
I also wanted to commend Jason on his
stand that he's not voting I personally
have not voted since the eighties you
know a two count vote now yellow set pal
okay uh I'm preparing a whole
presentation from the audience on Jason
not voting by the way that was this is a
guy who initially was known to us as
homeless Darryl then he became known to
us as diabetic Darryl then he became
known to us as Darrell in a ditch Darryl
in a field scrub okie Darryl we haven't
heard from him for a while and it's
always good to hear from him uh we like
to know that he's uh still listening to
the show always good to hear we're gonna
deal with Jason and his his skepticism
about voting a national elections a
little bit later on the bonus show we
will talk about another drone being shot
down this time by a 65 year old woman we
will talk about the dawn of the human
influenced age and we will also talk
about a mom who spent 35 days in jail
for bouncing a $29 check sign up and get
instant access to the bonus show at
david pakman.com slash membership